Petra is the holy city of a nomadic Arab tribe called the Nabateans...
...and they built this Petra as their holy city.
They made a fortune by trade and controlling caravan routes,...
...especially with myrrh and frankincense.
They would trade...
...around this entire Arabian Peninsula and the surrounding area...
...and that's how they made their fortune.
We have just arrived to one of the most important...
...and one of the famous landmarks and attractions at Petra and in Jordan.
This is actually the tomb of one the greatest kings of the Nabateans.
It's called "The Treasury" because it was believed...
...that there were some treasures stored in the top, but it's actually a burial tomb.
You can see so many different architectural designs from the Corinthian columns...
...to the Greek influence on the architecture and then all carved into the rock.